Bienvenue à tous dans ce petit vlog en Guadeloupe
C'es faux, c'est un effet au montage, regardez,  je suis dans mon studio
Hahaha
franchement, un enfant de 8 ans avec un fond vert
ferait des blagues meilleures que moi
Mais c'est pas grave,
On va fermer les yeux. Les amis aujourd'hui on vas réaliser un rêve.
Cette vidéo elle est pour l'enfant,
L'enfant que j'étais
il y a quelques années
l'enfant qui jouait à Counter Strike à longueur de journée
et qui essayait d'être le dernier en vie sur Dodos 2
les vrais savent...
L'enfant qui se disait :
"mais peut-être que dans 10, 20 ans,
quand on jouera,
on sera vraiment dans le jeu"
Et bah les amis je crois que le futur est arrivé
parce que
C'est possible !
Y 'a une pâle copie Russe de Counter Strike qui s'apelle Pavlov,
sauf que c'est en réalité virtuelle
et c'est vraiment les mêmes maps, les même armes, tout pareil,
c'est très bien, en plus ça nous permet de faire un peu de
GAMING!
Alors est-ce-que on vas aller voir les développeur de se jeux en leurs disant
"Ouais vous avez copier Counter Strike vous abusez"
PAS DU TOUT!
Merci les devs ! J'ai toujours voulu plonger dans les maps de Counter Strike !
Je m'en fou que vous ayez copié, allez-y!
Alors comment ça marche ?
Ah ok, comme ça.
Ensuite... Parce qu'il faut apprendre, ça veut dire qu'on va devoir tout faire nous même
*clic*
Ok...
Ah faut la charger !
C'est incroyable !
*coups de feu*
Comment je....
Bah ?
Comment on fait ?
Ah faut appuyer ok !
Ah !
Waouh !
Ah nan vraiment c'est...
Vraiment c'est fou!
Peut-être pour vous c'est rien, mais pour moi c'est incroyable. C'est le futur !
*coups de feu*
WAH ! Il faut tout que je prenne en main !
Une grenade, comment ça marche les grenades ?
*explosion*
*rire*
Oh ça va être périlleux !
Allez on rejoins une game sans plus tarder.
Jouer en ligne,
Dust 2 search & destroy. Attend,
ça veux dire qu'on a qu'une vie.
Je vais tomber avec des pros ?
HEYYYYY
Ah y a des Français c'est bien ça.
c'est Amixem ici là
AHHH
Vamos !
on vas prendre un digul un digul
oh p****n
oh lala!
oh mec c'est fou!
heyy
i follow you my friend
*coups de feu*
wooo!
ohhh!
comment je recharge?
non!
ah!
ah je peut pas le prendre!
je vais prendre son arme!
cover me!
oh!
ah nan mais c'est super dur !
ouai je sais ! t'es trop gentil à m'aider hein t'es trop mignon je t'aime!
vas y vas y on vas faire des interventions à deux on vas tout niquer mon pote
oh t'es un amour!
tient, je te donnes la mienne
*rire*
un ennemis!
*coups de feu*
pardon pardon! ça fait longtemps j'ai pas jouer à Counter!
y'a un mec, y'a un mec, fais des travers
ATTENTION A TOI JE M'EN CHARGE!
Attention à toi Papyrus!
AAAAHH
Ils sont tous morts! BAAAHH!
J'y vais au couteau
*coup de feu*
*rire*
J'vais m'y faire j'vais m'y faire
On est d'accord si j'marche ça tire pas droit
du coup, faut que j'm'arrête pour tirer
joueur : euuuuuuuh
joueur : ouaip
*coup de feu*
Vous en faites pas les gars j'l'e gère lui
OH J'L'AI EU ! OH NON Y'EN AVAIT UN AUTRE !!
J'en ai eu un ! J'ai tué un mec, j'ai tué un mec ! Regardez cette phrase, prenez du recul, c'est glauque !
Je vais devoir aller sur un serveur autre que ça parce que c'est trop galère là.
Oh non il était trop mignon, mais en fait c'est une game où on respon pas mais moi, il faut que je reprenne le contrôle en main, je suis trop mauvais là
Attendez, je vais me former, j'vais m'former et on va tout niquer, c'est partit
*Musique rock n roll* 🤨🤔
M*RDE !
C'est bon ! Mal grès cet incident, maintenant je suis près, je suis entraîné
Alors on va rejoindre une game, c'est partit !
OH P*TAIN ! OK ok ok ! C'est chacun pour sois ? C'est chacun pour sois (réponse à lui même)
Y a un mec là... *coups de feu*
OHHHHH ! Incroyable  !
AH ! Moins incroyable d'un coup ! Oh mec j'ai un snype' là ?
*Coups de feu*
Attend, mais attend , on est où là !
*coups de feu*
Ça dégage ! suivant ! *coups de feu*
Pardon, pardon ! Vite, vite comment on fait ? L'entrainement, l'entrainement.
*coups de feu*  AH ! *coups de feu
Attend, attend attend ! Mais attend !
Mais, y a, en fait, faut connaître comment recharger l'arme !  et y a plein d'armes différentes, c'est super dûr !
ok mec cette fois j'fais un carnage, un TABAC!
*coups de feu* nan nan ils sont partout, nan c'est abusé
nan ils sont partout vraiment quoi *coups de feu*
*coups de feu*
c'est
impossible faut avoir fait un service
militaire pour être bon *coups de feu*
oh on s'est tué mutuellement
*coups de feu* toi dégage
*rire* toi dégage
ah dès qu'on me donne une vraie arme je suis là hein
pauvre type, attention est-ce que vous êtes prêts à voir le move
le plus stylé du monde *coups de feu*
oh il est trop fort!!!!!
waw *coups de feu*
*recharge ses munitions* *coups de feu*
*coups de feu* pfff pfff pfff
ARRÊTE ARRÊTE AH LE COUTEAU *rire*
*rire* le duel de con j'ai plus
d'arme, attends excuse-moi je retire ton chargeur *rire*
*rire* quel duel
de con. moi je vais attendre là j'attends là et je mets un one shot
*coups de feu*
ouuuuuuh tu l'as pas venu venir
celle-là mon petit pote *coups de feu*
*coups de feu*
b*tard! *retire son casque et se retourne* pardon?
mec c'est tellement dur, défaite
d'accord *coups de feu*
tiens pauv' type! donc je suis combien? j'ai fais seize kills
eh! je suis pas dégueu mec nan mais il y a des
pros regardez! y'a des pros de ouf. mec je suis
en train de kiffer. j'ai l'impression d'être en 2030 là
c'est incroyable mec! *musique et coups de feu*
*coups de feu* TIENS
*coups de feu* ohhh!
ooooooooooooooh *coups de feu*
LE COUTEAU! LE COUTEAU! *bruit du fond vert cassé par lucas ;)) oh j'ai cassé un truc.
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOAAH, JE SUIS UNE SERIE OOOOOOOOOHHHH
oh oh oh ah non oh mec désolé
je crie, la seule manière d'exprimer ma joie est crier
je vais y aller comme ça en fait *musique rétro* ça marche pas du tout
je me suis emporté
*coups de feu* hop là! IL A RIEN VU!
ça dégage *coups de couteaux* ça dégage! suivant!
*coups de feu* *rire*
je connais pas bien la longueur de mon bras, c'est un problème que j'ai dans la vie c'est compliqué
bon alors j'aime bien cette map mais en gros on est trop les un sur les autres
puis y'a des mecs qui torchent la map depuis vingt-deux jours donc à un moment on va arrêter les bêtises
on va rejoindre une game où on est un peu moins collé
de toutes évidences je vais gerber
c'est évident! *bip*
oh c'est Nuketown, c'est Nuketown en version un peu cheap hein mais bon ça reste Nuketown
aller on y va! *rire*
*coups de feu*
ohlala comme je suis trop chaud
LITTLE PIECE OF SHIT
*coups de feu*
ATTENDS ATTENDS ATTENDS ATTENDS ATTENDS
*musique et coups de feu*
je t'ai dis d'attendre petite merde
OOH
*musique et coups de feu*
c'est trop dur! *bip*
vous voulez pas faire un team deathmatch sur *???* deux et on se met ensemble?
magnum dong vas-y et on te rejoint
magnum dong: ça roule!
aller! trop cool je me suis fais des potes sur le jeu mec! p*tain je suis content!
je vais jouer avec deux français!
en recherche et destruction ça veut dire qu'on a qu'une vie donc va falloir jouer bien quoi *bip*
qui veut la bombe?
vas-y je la prends! merde! vas-y prends la prends la
vas-y vamos les gars on va sur a tous
je vous suis hein je vous suis mais t'inquiète je vous couvre hein je suis un bon garde
y'a personne! ah sisi!
les gars faites gaffe y'a un mec là-haut là je surveille
il est mort il est mort
vas-y mets la bombe mets la bombe
derrière nous derrière nous derrière nous!
couvre moi! couvre moi!
attends je te couvre! je fais ce que je peux!
*coups de feu* merde merde
j'ai mis la bombe!
attends laisse moi laisse moi prendre son arme à lui là
'ten, prends mon arme prends mon arme elle est elle est chargée la mienne
il est là!
elle est pas chargée tu m'as menti! elle était pas chargée! *rire*
t'as pas pris la bonne
on va les ken les gars, on va les ken, on est la meilleure squad
dans l'dos dans l'dos! y'en a deux qui arrivent
ok ok *coups de feu*
*coups de feu*
oui!
vous les avez eu?
OOHHHHHHHHHHH
ouiiiiiiii! p*tain on est bon les gars on est bon
ok les gars suivez-moi vous en faites pas je suis un bet de mec
attends passe devant ptetre passe devant ptetre toi quand même juste toi
ouais comme ça c'est moi qui meurt?
nan pas du tout c'est pas pour ça... euh.... je veux montrer aux gens comme t'es fort et tout
nan y'a personne
alors on y va
y'en a un! nan!
nan on a perdu magnum nan!
pas le temps! on prends la bombe!
ok on y va! p*tain quelle lourde perte c'est horrible
mets la bombe mets la bombe mets la bombe
je surveille à droite
*coups de feu* OH
*coups de feu* il était caché le bâtard
p*tain je vais l'avoir c'est mon un contre un le monde me regarde
*coups de feu*
OOOOOOHOHOHOH
ouh je l'ai! nan!
oh nan il t'a eu mon pote
je vais poser la bombe! je vais te faire honneur mon pote  je vais te faire honneur mon pote
*musique triste*
MERDE
comment on pose la bombe
*coups de feu*
p*tain
NAAAAAAN
merde
j'ai fais n'importe quoi j'ai honte *bip*
on va les contourner venez avec moi on on va les contourner on va les contourner les gars
on est malin
*coups de feu* il est pas armé il est pas armé
espèce de monstre! il avait pas d'arme!
*coups de feu*
OOOOOOOOH
faut que je ramasse un truc attends
c'est bon je l'ai
ils sont derrière? *coups de feu*
NAN NAN J'EN AVAIS EU UN
ils nous baisent la gueule là
attends tu sais quoi?
les gars je vais y aller au couteau ok
vas-y vas-y les gars attirez les
laissez moi passez devant j'ai un couteau laissez moi
*musique*
y'en a un!
mais nan?!
J'Y VAIS
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH
*coups de feu*
oh j'en ai eu un les gars *rire*
mais c'est quoi c'bordel?!
j'en ai eu un!
p*tain ça c'est mes années seize qui reviennent ça
le skill il revient petit à petit on le voit *bip*
passe devant passe devant passe devant
passe devant je te cover je te cover
personne!
personne? on avance
ils sont pas là! demi-tour!
mais nan! mais t'es mauvais là!
*coups de feu*
bien joué à toi
merde y'en a un autre j'ai plus de balles!
je te cover je te cover
c'est bon j'ai rechargé
*coups de feu*
waw t'es chaud!
eh high five high five
ah merde dommage
*bip*
allez venez avec moi les gars là je vous jure je fais un 1 v 5
regardez bien j'ai la puissance en moi là
LET'S GO
y'a personne y'a personne
à droite?
oh non
là y'en a un là
*coups de feu*
je l'ai eu ou pas?
nan il s'en va!
*coups de feu*
nan! p*tain c'est chaud là
b,b,b,b,b
ouais ils sont sur b b b b
wow t'as essuyé des tirs
*musique*
*musique et coups de feu*
wouw
gg!
une équipe qui gagne
ohlala on est chaud les gars!
les amis!
ah
mec une heure quarante de réalité virtuelle
c'est genre neuf heures de jeu sur le pc hors casque de réalité virtuelle
je suis dans un malaise
t'es dans ton jacuzzi je suis dans mon envie de vomir
les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
désolé c'était un peu le cafouillage mais j'avais pas joué avant la vidéo
et mec j'ai une gerbe
oh j'ai une gerbe regardez je suis blanc
et je pue en plus de ça
c'est ça l'avenir du jeu vidéo?
cette couleur boursin et sentir très fort la sueur
c'était quand même cool de tester ça avec vous
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo, on se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine
portez vous bien!
à très vite! je vais direct aux toilettes
oh bah!
merci Clément!
j'ai plus qu'à y aller ici maintenant haha
AH
*outro*